I mean I would love to sit in your chair
and interview all a great living artists
I mean interview people like Jeff Koons
like Damon hostage to use some of the
most famous names but I find nothing
more stimulating as a direct contact
with living artists with highly creative
individuals nothing is more stimulating
the wonderful thing is with jeff koons
he is one of the most articulate people
I've ever met and you just ask him
something and then you the rest would
come by itself and I actually invited
him to give a lecture many years back in
Geneva I think it was something like 15
years back and he showed some large
slides of his work which some of his
work at the time was quite provocative
and at the time several clients got up
in the middle of the lecture and left
middle of the talk and so I said oh my
god I must have lost some important
clients there but the next day those
same clients called me up and said
listen I'm deeply shocked that somebody
who looks as prim and proper as you
would invite such an individual showing
such shocking work but despite the fact
that I'm so shocked there's something I
want to sell why don't you come out to
my place and I'll show you that work so
even by being utterly shocked those
clients then wanted to sell their work
so us so it can have a very fatherly
you